assalammualaikum white metal a better
care to box the sisters and their
friends welcome to this video this is
our second shoe we recorded one
yesterday and not with when I'm gonna
put that out and we decided for this out
we would explain why we'll give you a
little preview of that video as you guys
know there's a video that's gone viral
where there's a sister who's doing a
very inappropriate dance with another
man in public and this has gone viral so
we decided to do a video last night
which we did and we was really upset to
be honest and I'm sure I love you guys
obstacle because it's sad to see that
you know it's just that we have that
thing for our religion and we understand
a lot of us hate seeing certain things
done by practicing looking individuals
yeah if that makes sense
so now the thing is we're gonna play the
the interview because we actually I
spoke to the sister her family contacted
me and I spoke to her personally you're
gonna hear the interview but sadly as us
Muslims we when they see such videos we
take it too far we start insulting the
individual swearing insult ain't calling
them all kinds of names and it's taking
our boundary you know we should hate the
sin rather than the sinner yes the
action is wrong it's very very wrong it
was really bad but it does not give us a
right to start naming the individual
believe me behind this I'm sure you need
to understand that I've said this in the
video is obvious this video I said I
really want to understand the psychology
behind why would the sister do that you
know anybody like why would they really
do that and after speaking feel like it
makes you realize this is there's a
bigger story behind it it doesn't mean
it's right what she's done it just shows
that different people are suffering from
different things and sometimes they do
things that they don't want to and
believe us like believe me we all go
through this different people work in
different ways you know when they when
people are tested you can you can be
tested and you can react in a totally
different way to me you know I could
just say you know I'm gonna go totally
silent and move off the scene you can
say you know I'm gonna go full-out you
see I'm trying to say so yes this video
what was it about like to be honest like
how was our attitude yesterday compared
to today you know and even though you
haven't heard the interview but I have
yeah but I've given you a brief info
just to give a briefing like how would
you feel and yesterday to now obviously
yesterday we will very
fused because the video the the nature
of the video is something that is in its
nature very inappropriate and we were
very very confused because in the DAO
scene we've been in it for years now we
never seen anything like this people ask
us for advice every single day but we
never come across anything of this so to
us it was very very hard to comprehend
what someone could be going through to
be doing something like that while
wearing the hijab because like we get
messages I'm sure you do as well like
about people
suicidal cases and what non-suicidal
this day and my boyfriend left me and
whatnot and you know even I've been
raped what do I do you know a lot of
very very tough situations which we
actually can understand and like advise
about but like with this we were just
speechless what can we even say about
this
so obviously unexpected a sista and it
just goes to show you that when someone
does something there is always a
background story doesn't mean it's
justifiable doesn't mean it's fine but
there is a background story and a lot of
brothers and sisters were actually
acting their friends to come watch the
video laughing brother like well like
wait that was your own 6-1 Bravo you
know I heard who runs a Instagram page
and Islamic Instagram page I think his
friend saying yo this is your girl come
get you go like is this is not the way
that unless Tim should behave this is
not the kind of things that Muslims
should say and in regards to some of
these Instagram pages we do one you're
gonna come to we're gonna come to what
an actual name then we're gonna put the
names out you're gonna see it yeah and
the police is involved and we ask you to
report these pages we're gonna come to
that later on chala but let's just show
you guys into a preview of how they just
a new clip of yesterday's video how me
and Musa were and you can see from my
face how angry we were let's just
quickly watch that what lies there's one
thing I just want to know what
psychology what a mentality what brain
what cells in your brain are you serving
to not understand like all of a second I
am wearing a hijab I also have a loose
clothing doesn't that in that the acts
of action items way now doesn't that
make you think you know what
I'm representing some for my rather
marking my hand and I know that Muslims
knew that my swag is something related
to Islam while Maggie I have to be
careful to undoing in public you look
like a proper Muslim doing that in front
of a guy and his non Muslims Muslims
watching you I forget that that hell's
there for you
okay guys so you saw for yourself like
how frustrated me and Musa that I was I
could be out just banging in the table
right I was just frustrated I was out
why would somebody do that and it was
just it taught me a lesson like in a way
where I was like okay I should be angry
for the sake of the religion but I
should always think okay there must be
reason Judy I'm sure I learned a big
lesson myself but not to carry on any
further let's go and listen to the
interview from the sister and hear her
side like I'm sorry I didn't ask her
this I actually interviewed her I said
system why did you do this but let's
hear it for our self inshallah so we
have your permission you are the sister
of the younger sister yes yeah okay we
have your permission just to hear her
side for clarification so that people
can hear her side and understand that
you know perfect yes yes is why did you
do that
problems are you suffering from because
you said you like you're getting
counseling is it a mental issues like
depression I think it was last year when
I was going through depression
I've been going to Christians for $13
doing one this is the work of Shaytan
believers with the only reason I'm doing
this is because unfortunately people are
going to watch the video and judge it
based on them so don't cry while a allah
subhanho wa taala is the most merciful
and don't ever and you said you started
to practice so sister were like I make
dwarfy inshallah now you get well don't
be upset that is good that one part the
fact that you're crying one like this is
a sign of repentance and removes and it
shows that you have Iman yeah so so
don't worry so okay
okay yeah okay yeah please if you do
have this video can you - me
can you take em social medias like help
me
bless you son so clarifying thanks for
allowing people to hear your side and
inshallah our our aim as my team is to
get these videos down and inshallah just
give a little general advice it above
the sisters inshallah thanks who speak
in fact so allowing me to share through
the TV lishala
once again my advice to you sister don't
ever ever ever forget that and also if
you want company
so okay guys so you heard it for
yourself and what like I'm being honest
it changed my perspective a lot
it made me shape up my thinking a little
bit more as well and he upset me I'm
being honest like well night when I
heard her cry
it just like it really made my heart
sink cuz I was just like cuz she does
have a fatherly figure she's lost
someone dear yeah in a family just like
suffering from psychological issues
since since she was 13 depression
self-harm in and one thing that I really
want you to and one thing but I want you
to elaborate on Musa is that the fact
that she said that when she was there at
the moment when the song came on the
shaitaan like this is so crucial because
we always talked about this music how
elaborate on it because this is like you
know because it's something that you've
suffered from before Julie I'm trying to
see environment music in the weakness
you know you know there's certain things
yeah this certain sense that for example
you see myself and Ally
masha'allah practicing brothers whatnot
you try to give advice on youtube and
whatnot but and you wouldn't expect us
to fall into certain sins but reducing
because of our human beings yeah so what
you have to understand is even use of
ally Salaam when we he was in a certain
situation when a woman was approaching
him in a seductive way allah subhanaw
taala expresses to us in the quran in
surah yousuf that had he not seen you
know the subhanAllah like the miracles
of allah subhanaw taala the work of
allah subhanaw taala
even him subhanAllah it could have
affected him yeah and he was a prophet
of allah subhanaw taala that's not to
say you so what it's like a week but
what is this got to show you when we
come across certain things and we see
certain things and hear certain things
they affect our heart and when they
affect our heart they can cause us to
commit grave sins so for example if I
was to see a woman coming at me naked
this is that one it can really affect
the man in exactly the same way this
sister she expresses that I didn't want
to do it this star what not but it was a
specific song one she makes it very
clear this is why music is Haram
this is one music it's the work of
Shaitaan when you listen to music you
think oh that's minor but then the
things that will lead you to are not
minor exactly so it's like it's it's
something it is like music and hearts
look if you're in let's say in her own
relationship her own volition and
listening to love songs while I I'm
telling you they leave me I come from
the society where I'm telling you my
family members have committed they fuel
their self and believe me me personally
I'm just I'm just telling you so you
guys understand and learn in my journey
we're not be in certain relationship
when I would hear these kind of songs
relating to love songs whatever it may
be it affects your heart won't lie a key
the I know brothers and at times you
feel suicidal is they see you in for a
break up in your Akash whatever is your
engineer when you hit is your heart will
lie I'm telling you by Allah when you
you know know you know you just thinking
you know what I can't handle this
anymore this is the fakeness Muse you
know when you see people at Nicki Minaj
whatnot yeah talking about their private
parts talking about how they've got big
eyes and he's talking about how they
they done inappropriate dances on stage
and whatnot in order this yeah this is
gonna affect you this is when you
listening to this this is what's gonna
influence you yeah and this is what does
influence people yeah it just
to show you music is something that can
lead you to that this sister is no
different than any other sister out
there yeah she and she's only 17 she's
only 17 so many seventeen your sisters
unfortunately they listen to music yeah
and they're probably watching and
thinking I'd never do that one not yeah
I bet you at home you're doing the same
thing yeah I bet you are home you're
doing the same thing what's the
difference a brother see my brothers
same with guys because they they in that
mentality you need to understand what if
I come to evidence in you're a liar yeah
you're a liar you're like broth you can
you're a liar
these fearful people in these songs they
don't get care about you and their
cousin huh they they talk about woman
like they're who they couldn't I can't
believe it sure they're calling woman
holds your days do that and then we've
got the same females in the club's dance
into it but yes I seen your mama your
skanking to it your mum is this and then
oh yeah yeah logic anyways guys listen
what we're gonna do now is we're gonna
mention the pages that we'll be sharing
this video they're not taking it down
because to them likes and shares is more
important so report these pages and what
like how you can answer alone to their
judgment
so report this Peters well you're gonna
play the video and you know by looking
at some advantages and they put their
name there yeah these big and just put
his name in her a big yes and the way
spell a stuck for Allah when he posted
this it's very clear to me I assumed
that these guys are Muslim yeah
now some of these people are Muslim
these people need to fear Allah you're
just as bad you you were saying that
she's this she's yeah yeah you are just
as bad as someone who does something bad
you are just as much just sharing it
you'll probably worse me cuz you're
sharing it to thousands of people
you're worse than her you're worse than
your promoting it yeah so you need to
fear Allah because she could change yeah
in five years she's change he's
practicing she's wearing the club she's
married she's got children and because
of you you evil people because I'm sorry
I'm game passionate because of you yeah
because of you she has to deal with hate
she has to deal with pain and suffering
yeah because how has been remembers that
hundred thousand people have seen her
doing something in front of a guy and
her and that's on your shoulders it's on
your shrine does remind me to be killed
when mention these when you're in your
grave no no everyone will die one day
yes when you die
you will be accountable for everything
yeah anyone can dine and and share this
video with those pages of one life if
this doesn't you know any advance
this is doesn't make you take it down we
don't know what lie if you know any
admins of these pages yeah send it to
them yes and also we want to tell you
guys that the reason we're sharing these
pages and you're gonna end up seeing the
video is because we spoke to the family
the family said look they already
sharing it yeah at least mention it
because the police is involved and
inshallah just report the channel once
you put these pages in chawla guys when
you go on the page click report page yes
harassment bullying yes when you go on
the page on Instagram this report the
page yes every single one of you if you
want to see a change yeah if you
actually want to do something instead of
talking nonsense in the comments yeah
let's all report the page you get these
pages delete yeah exactly not doing I'm
good man exactly so guys thank you for
watching hope you guys have benefited
hope you guys have learned if we've done
anything forgive us it's our shortfall
like I said before inshallah share this
do do something if this was your own
system of light you would not stand
still you will do something so internal
share this with your friends and family
and get those pages reported inshallah
and taking the taken down and Shama
that's about it hope you guys are
benefited assalamu alaikum wa
rahmatullah better care to do check out
our reaction with Musa Moses channel
shala very soon goodbye